pourquoi réélire le président Roth coq il a
distribué six millions de dollars de l'
argent des contribuables à des
entreprises de technologie spatiale comme Vaz tech industries il a
construit un mur nous protégeant de la
menace des illégaux il a pris position et a
défendu notre deuxième amendement avec
vengeance et pour renforcer notre national
l'économie à un niveau record il a rendu la
marijuana légale dans 48 États mes compatriotes
américains c'est un groobee depuis des années
mais il reste encore tellement à
accomplir pour moi gagner n'était que le
début réélire refdoc un nom que vous
allumez un visage en qui vous pouvez avoir confiance